[Music]
thank you
former Supreme Court Justice Jonathan
sumption writes this week's cover piece
about the case for leaving the European
convention on human rights the
convention he says has become intrusive
and banal to expand on his argument
Jonathan joins me now alongside the
former Attorney General Dominic Reeve
this week Jonathan you write the cover
piece which is about the case for the UK
actually leaving the European convention
on human rights yes can you explain your
argument for us
I've got no problem at all about the
text of the convention
I do have quite a serious problem
about the way in which the text has been
treated by the European Accord of human
rights in strasbour
since the 1970s they have operated in
accordance with what they call a living
instrument Doctrine
and that essentially has been treated as
a way of
expanding on the text by process of
extrapolation and analogy so as to
produce a very large number of Rights
some of which are Loosely ancillary to
existing rights but many of which are
freestanding
uh I think that this is an essentially
legislative process and involves a user
patient of the function of democratic
legislatures
we do not need the Human Rights
Convention in order to protect human
rights but I certainly wouldn't like to
see it abolished a less we replace it
with something equivalent so what I
would suggest is that we should replace
it with something that would look very
much the same as the convention but
which would not be subject to the
jurisdiction of the Strasbourg Court
would you make a Jonathan argument there
start with something we agree or I'm
certainly uh in agreement with him that
if the United Kingdom were to withdraw
from the European convention on human
rights
uh but continue for example to operate
the human rights act as its billowed
domestic Bill of Rights
then I think our human rights in this
country would continue to be pretty well
protected there is a risk that in
certain circumstances on the Declaration
of incompatibility Parliament and
government might decide to do nothing
about it but Jonathan has a perfectly
good point that that can be argued to be
within the way a democracy operates if
it's fully debated in Parliament
but that for me is not why we signed up
to the European convention on human
rights in the first place we signed up
to it because it was an international
treaty that was intended to confer
International benefits on the United
Kingdom raising the standards of human
rights in other European countries which
in my view it has done exceptionally
well
and at the same time showing that we
were prepared to be bound by this
International Convention which is
ultimately interpreted by an
international tribunal the court of
human rights as a way of persuading
those other countries to adhere to it
and the difficulty is that if you decide
to leave it you are going to have a
whole series of consequences that will
flow from it and can be listed quite
easily some of them one of the early
ones is that our trading cooperation
agreement with the EU will undoubtedly
be jeopardized it may be possible to
work around it our participation in the
Horizon Project would become impossible
because it requires data sharing and
data sharing is seen as being absolutely
underpinned uh posts are leaving the EU
by shared adherence to the convention
um and in the context of Northern
Ireland there would be some significant
issues about where Northern Ireland
remained within the Ambit of the
convention or not and how you would do
that if a sovereign state withdraws
because it is explicit and implicit in
the Good Friday Belfast agreement that
we would be there so there would be very
significant consequences and like
everything else in an international
treaty you should if you're considering
withdrawing it or participating it you
should be weighing the pros and the cons
and where I think I disagree with
Jonathan is that when it comes to
looking at the downsides of this then
whilst I accept that the court has
occasionally made decisions which I
disagree with and I actually think have
been rather foolish at times but then
even our own Supreme quarters
occasionally done decisions which I
thought were rather foolish domestically
um but when you actually look at the way
this course is now operating
particularly since Ken Clark and I
negotiated the Brighton declaration in
2012 and changed the way it operated in
practice we've had very little
difficulty adhering to it and actually
the number of cases
which have caused a ripple since have
been almost non-existent I think last
year the best I would try to look it up
before I came here but as far as I could
see there were only two judgments
against the UK that could be regarded as
covering new ground as opposed to cases
where we hadn't dealt with a previous
judgment until another judgment came
along and they were both matters where
actually the government was perfectly
happy one was bereavement support grants
and uh discrimination and the other one
was about journalists being harassed by
the police for tweets at that the
journalists considered was acceptable
and the police didn't and a wrongful
arrest which followed
um most of the big issues prisoner
voting whole life tariffs have all been
resolved without anybody really being
aware it's happened so whilst I accept
that this course isn't perfect no Human
Institution is perfect I think that the
reputational consequences to the United
Kingdom of leaving and the Practical
consequences of leaving vastly outweigh
any possible advantage that it might
confer using well I fundamentally
disagree with much of that
um
most International multilateral treaties
are designed to enable one to achieve
things internationally which we could
not achieve on our own
um
this is a rather special case because
the Human Rights Convention is a treaty
which deals with matters every single
one of which we could deal with on our
own now what dominic says is well it
encourages human rights in other places
and that was certainly the rather
patronizing basis on which we acceded to
it originally
we basically said to ourselves that we
already have all of the these benefits
they've been part of English law for a
long time which was mainly but not
entirely true we are joining this
because we want to confer the advantages
that we've had for a long time on these
Ben knighted Europeans
that was essentially the attitude I am
skeptical about how much we have
actually achieved internationally
uh there are countries which have been
released from Decades of turini in
Eastern Europe which who have been
desperate to improve their human rights
record
and have successfully done it I believe
that they would have done it whether the
United Kingdom was party to this treaty
or not there are other countries like
Belarus and Russia and to some extent
turkey which have set their face against
giving effective
scope to the Human Rights Convention in
spite of the fact that they were parties
to it and no amount of adverse judgment
has improved their degree of compliance
Russia was expelled from the Council of
Europe and last year banaris has not
been expelled but its human rights
record is absolutely dismal the human
the participation of the United Kingdom
in the convention has made absolutely no
difference to them there are some things
which I would accept first of all I
would accept that we if we withdrew from
the convention we would not be able to
withdraw from it in respect of Northern
Ireland because The Good Friday
agreement specifically requires that we
confer on them not just human rights but
the human rights envisaged in the uh in
the convention so I think that unless
something could be negotiated with the
Irish government which I regard as most
unlikely we would have to leave Northern
Isle in the convention system
I don't accept that it would create
problems with the EU the EU treaty
requires its members to have
satisfactory arrangements for preserving
human rights doesn't require its members
to adhere to the convention although
they all do it seems to me therefore
that if we had a system of human rights
which was dependent on enforcement by
independent judges who are perfectly up
to the job which that would be the case
in this country I think the EU would
probably accept that the problem really
is that we have to decide not whether we
like this or that or the other decision
that the Strasbourg Court makes we
people will no doubt different that the
real question is how do you make law for
a democracy and the problem that the
strasbour court raises is that whereas
if you have a whole only domestic system
of Human Rights protection if something
goes is wrong if courts make cine
decisions which they sometimes do I
quite agree with Dominic about that
you can deal with it you can correct it
because you are basically a masters of
your the national scheme yourself
but there is absolutely no way of
correcting the errors of the Strasbourg
Court the members of the Council of
Europe have no input whatever into its
decision-making process that Dominic
cites the Bratton declaration I have to
say that the Brighton declaration has in
my view made very little difference to
the way that they operate I spoke
earlier the other day to two members of
the Court who said oh that we look
intensely with great care of the
subsidiarity and all these other things
which many of which are basically
reflected right
but you have the test is whether this
can be seen in the decisions and I don't
believe that it can
Well I obviously disagree with that and
just to give a couple of examples
firstly there is a degree of dialogue
between our own National courts and the
Strasbourg Court which can continue even
when a strasbour courts made a decision
that we think may be wrong or an
examples of this are around
um and
um the Strasbourg called Hadas listen to
what our own Supreme Court does so for
example political advertising which I
think was seen as being a restriction on
freedom of expression when it was first
being considered in Strasbourg once the
Supreme Court had explained why we had
such rules on managing political
advertising it stops saying with rules
on hearsay in Criminal Courts You could
argue that actually it was a very
extensive dialogue over prisoner voting
So eventually it was resolved by a
minute change to the prison regulations
and I accept this is not a perfect
system but it is one where there's
undoubtedly dialogue and the dialogue is
all the better when there's trust one of
the problems is when the United Kingdom
starts huffing and puffing and saying
it's about to pull out when if you want
my personal opinion there is no Prospect
whatsoever of it happening under the
present government at all so this is
another sort of pre-party conference
puff I have to say to you every time
that happens it reduces the trust and
the reduction in a trust then leads to
examples like applying rule 39 and
giving an interim order to prevent
deportation to Rwanda which I happen to
think was completely unnecessary because
I at least do have confidence that if
the United Kingdom were ultimately have
a judgment against it after it had
deported somebody to Rwanda we'd have
brought them back but equally turning
that into some great issue in my view
when it's just a procedural matter
um is to exaggerate the problems and
failing to see the advantages and I do
also fundamentally disagree about the
issue about impact
and does it take two examples
and adherence to the convention is seen
as a benchmark and standard of Human
Rights it even has a positive impact
outside of convention countries Theresa
May's willingness to take the brick bats
from the uh tabloid press over Abu
qatada ultimately led the Jordanian
government changing its own criminal
justice system to prevent the
admissibility of evidence that might
have been obtained under torture which
is something I think we would all think
was a good thing and at the moment in
Azerbaijan in the Ghana parabakh you
have a humanitarian crisis brought on by
the fact that the inhabitants who are
legally in Azerbaijan whatever has been
happening there previously are in great
fear of persecution in their lives the
azeri government of all its faults is a
signatory member of the convention and
will be placed under very considerable
pressure as to how it operates in
respect of a minority Community all
those things in my view are advantageous
and I happen to think that Jonathan is
underestimating this bit of UK soft
power at best we've been seen as leaders
in this and it has particularly in
communist the ex-communist countries
after the war came down which often had
no traditions of democratic
accountability at all and a lot of
authoritarian administrative decision
making it's made a very great impact and
finally I disagree because Jonathan
characterized International treaties
as being there to regulate relations
between states no I didn't do that well
that's roughly but what I what I I since
the second world war a loss of
international treaties about the
behavior of States towards their own
citizens and the willingness of states
to circumscribe their sovereignty in
order to achieve certain standards and
obviously a question arises
but on the question of democracy
is that acceptable or not but I think in
the overall context of democratic
government and trying to achieve both
democracy and freedom and the rule of
law I think it's a balance that we've
probably got just about right I'm not
saying that there aren't frictions and
I'm not saying that the court in
Strasbourg always gets it right but I
think that to Simply say you should just
leave this entirely to Sovereign
governments to get on with I think we
will then find that overall the standard
of human rights that we enjoy
particularly on the European continent
and slip
well I think that the all the advantages
which you cite are perfectly capable of
being achieved if we have a reputation
for defending human rights domestically
I don't think that we need the
convention in order to do it I entirely
agree that there is dialogue between our
courts and the courts and the stressberg
court and I also agree that there are
some cases in which the Strasbourg court
has usually without admitting it being
prepared to back down but for every case
like that there are a number of cases in
which
they have not backed down I mean just to
cite two examples
the strasba court has made policing in
countries of the Council of Europe
including ourselves very much more
difficult by considerably restricting
the amount of intelligence that they can
retain or the kind of evidence that they
can use another example the Strasbourg
court has made it extremely difficult
for European armies to participate
effectively in peacekeeping operations
by purporting to extend
the convention to the activities of
armed forces in places like Afghanistan
and Iraq
in the process it has made it extremely
difficult to retain prisoners of War to
the immense dismay not only of countries
with peacekeeping forces in these places
but also of the Red Cross I think that
Dominic is absolutely right to say that
the picture is not is not an even one
there are examples where the system
works satisfactorily but there are too
many examples of cases where it doesn't
work at all satisfactorily for this to
be a sensible way of making law for our
society I think you both agree on the
fact that I think debater on the East HR
has often been quite the facile one and
then yes and I wouldn't pin it on
immigration which is I think to do with
Human Rights Convention the problems
that we're having due to other factors
and I wouldn't therefore want to
withdraw simply because of EG they
admittedly disgraceful behavior of the
Strasbourg Court over rule 39 and Rwanda
and I got a little pesh time for the
Rwanda scheme I don't think it's going
to work but I think that the way that
the British courts were treated over
that was actually the British government
was treated it was frankly disgraceful
but I don't think I should take single
incidents and treat them as a reason for
withdrawing that that is just rhetoric I
would certain My Views are potentially
based on the experience of Decades of
Strasbourg at jurisprudence
and I regret it I originally felt we
should perhaps wait to see whether they
could perform themselves internally
whether the Brighton declaration would
work I have very reluctantly come to an
inclusion that this is too ungainly an
institution you know with too much
Esprit decor and too much ideological
commitment to change and how do you see
this debate unfolding in the coming
years I mean the conservatives of teen
talking about it had the conversations
normally mentions but uh where do you
see it and when my position is a
minority position both in the country at
large and I think in in Parliament and
indeed even within the conservative
party no I recognize that but the fact
that I'm in a minority isn't going to
stop me from pointing out the costs that
we have to pay
Dominique do you think it's going to be
a stable part of British life all
debates from the East Asia the debate a
rallies that ECHL has been running a
long time admittedly it's principally
been focused on getting rid of the Human
Rights Act having a Bill of Rights and
somehow staying compliant with the echr
even if though there's a desire to make
it non-compliant and and that has been a
15-year utterly sterile argument led to
the sacking of at least one attorney
general I can think of uh and uh the uh
and at the end of it we have made
absolutely no progress because it was a
very poorly thought out scheme now
I accept actually that logically leaving
the echr entirely has a more logical
um ring to it but it also brings with it
these consequences and it's obviously an
area where Jonathan and I whilst we
agree on some things also I think have a
sort of fundamentally different take on
the advantages of internationalism I was
attorney general when the court of Human
Rights started creating difficulties
over detaining Battlefield combatants in
Afghanistan and I entirely agree with
him I think they have got the wrong end
of the stick very badly but actually
some subsequent jurisprudence suggests
that we've got out of that and they've
now understood that in fact
International humanitarian law has got
to be taken into account the law of the
battlefield
so
whilst I accept that there are hiccups
irritations things I disagree with and
like any International court with 46
judges on it there are going to be
issues around that
um actually I don't think it is doing us
anything like as much harm as Jonathan
thinks and I think it is a vehicle for
continuing to do good and for that
reason I think that this argument uh
will not go anywhere because I don't
think a UK prime minister whether it's
Rishi sunak or turns out to be care
starmer after the next election is going
to be minded to start tinkering with our
adherence to a treaty which and here I
disagree with Jonathan is seen as really
fundamentally important by our EU
Partners in terms of our continuing
relationship now we're out of the EU so
the political consequences of that being
so profound and with it The Economic
Consequences that might go with it I
don't think it'll happen we look forward
to covering that debate in The Spectator
thank you Jonathan thank you Dominic
[Music]
thank you